[Applause]
i'm at this hospital right i'm getting
my finger checked out
clearly broke a bone that's the type of
force i punch with i broke up snap the
bone right off my bone
it's called an abrasion
is that how he said it all right hey
hey oh gosh right that [ __ ] is is that
how he said it
bro it's called an abrasion that's what
you got
i chipped the bone right off my bone bro
oh words
yeah oh [ __ ] it's called an abrasion you
know that's what that was an abrasion
yeah
you better brace yourself for this
information i'm about to give you right
now because
seriously you lost a legit piece of bone
a piece of bone came right off my bone i
don't know where that [ __ ] is well it's
in there
abrasion is just a scrape that's what i
thought an abrasion was like operation
operation son i don't know it was one of
those shits it was it was severe
and you said inspiration in harry potter
when you go from one place to the other
shut the [ __ ] up in this he was indian
you didn't know he was
and yeah he could have said anything
really at that point right so
my man told me how much i [ __ ] my [ __ ]
up i had to go get the x-rays and all
that
then he starts telling me his political
views i got a feeling he's listening to
the podcast maybe before maybe or not
maybe he's seen some of the weekly
pieces i'm not certain but he felt very
comfortable talking to me about the
world as he sees it
[Laughter]
guy said that what's happening right now
with coronavirus is a
cool this is a doctor oh a coo
he's a cocoon
i gotta shoot you for that i
yeah yes we need that in slow-mo
i got him right in his [ __ ] nose bruh
[ __ ]
all right first shot dangerous bro okay
ready yeah that was just that was that
how was that i'm mad you did that to my
friend al
all right relax we're not doing
retaliation shots okay this is how
this is how things get dangerous this is
montague capulet [ __ ] we gotta stop it
right now
truce
[Laughter]
no truth truth hey truce bro it's a
truce right
you have to do that to your brother all
right anyway
so
hey that's why he's still angry me to
this day okay
so the guy says this is a coup he we
should have opened up months ago
he thinks it's a coup to get trump out
of office that's what he was saying
he goes he tells me as he goes 94
of the people that got corona didn't die
from corona they had comorbidities
that other situations was causing them
to die
only six percent die from corona did you
know that information you didn't want to
tell it to us no i didn't know that
information and you didn't
you did i did and you never thought that
you could share it with us did you
what are you talking about you're just
gonna you're just gonna go to your
wedding
you're just gonna go to your wedding
common knowledge well all of us were
terrified
son you [ __ ] 12 times a day so if you
get the corona
you're gonna have like floods of [ __ ]
flying out your ass so let's not take
that chance
you get sick every other week so if you
get corroded it might not be good for
you one more time
i remember as it hit you you weren't
even ready
like it hit you and you stood for a
minute like did he just shoot the [ __ ]
anyway point is this guy's saying that
fat
people are really the cause of corona
being an epidemic or a pandemic
didn't we know that that was all
pre-existing but i didn't know it was 94
i didn't know the fat people were
causing the [ __ ] world to go down
it's not
just fabulous it's fat people bro
for the sake of this podcast it's fat
people
now pile on everybody do what fat people
do to themselves
do what they do to their plate at a
buffet pile on
no but for real we were talking about
this yesterday the one thing
the one reason why it's always been
messed up to make fun of fat people is
because it's self-inflicted right the
fatness only affects themselves
right now we could tease them be like
our [ __ ] with our flights you know
they're
you know whatever next to us and
touching us on the subway
this at the other all these other [ __ ]
up things
that's annoying to look at i don't know
you can pick whatever you want
whatever okay you can't find a mask that
fits your whole face
touching on the trains no when that
thigh hits your thigh bro then their
[ __ ] is mad hot turn
ankle thigh out that's your problem but
it's not touching someone else's thigh
you never had a fat person's thigh touch
your thigh
and the top is [ __ ] hot the bottom is
cold
because they don't have that good blood
circulation hot pocket ass died
well i have many at times hal sorry not
all of us drive a tesla
you [ __ ] such pieces of [ __ ] you're
blowing all your bullets so fast you're
right bro
heard that baby hurt that baby it could
happen
point is
we've never been able to make fun of fat
people because what they did only hurt
themselves that was the idea
right it was a victimless crime being
fat the only victim was you
okay now that we know that they just
caused global economic collapse
and that they're putting massive
pressure not only their weight but
actually like structural pressure on our
hospitals and medical system
and taking ventilators away from people
who decide not to just eat oreos their
whole life
and actually killing people from being
fat i think we can make fun of fat
people now
i didn't want to agree until you said
that last line the ventilators right
no now we can make fun of fat people so
i feel like
if we can make fun of fat people i'm
willing to agree with pretty much
anything
i think it's all good no you used to be
fat i was a fat you were a fat my jeans
are supposed to be fat
somebody might call them sweatpants
i'll shoot myself god
so i just understand that it's not
something that you necessarily have to
do
most of us cannot be fat that's right
how did you stop being fat
shame a lot of shame you know what i
mean a lot of family telling me i was
fat i had a uncle
every time he would see me eating i'll
stay at his house pretty much all summer
every time he just be like god
enough of that you're gonna lose weight
he just says god
it's just oh my god he was disgusted yes
yeah just come on just grab your stomach
indians don't give a [ __ ] you get enough
shame like i should do something about
this
so maybe instead of this like love is
love [ __ ] all these fat models stomping
down the runway
maybe what we do is we start going stop
killing everybody in the world from
corona
one you you two ew
and three stop being selfish and taking
up all the ventilators you need a
ventilator just to walk down the street
you already own
[Laughter]
real talk imagine that you need a
ventilator just to sleep at night
and then you're gonna go take a
ventilator from a skinny person that got
corona
it's more emotionally good for you i
guess to be nice but it's physically
better to shame them
and now you've got time to work on the
self-worth issues because you're going
to live longer because you're not fat
exactly we got to do the right thing
mark which is you tell me
click click click click
no for real what do you think the right
thing is what do you think the solution
is if you get it wrong i'm shooting you
right in your [ __ ]
massive eyebrow bridge what a target
that should be casting a shadow on all
what a thing to make fun of i don't even
know what the [ __ ] a eyebrow
is son you don't notice it all the way
around he got that neanderthal yeah
you don't notice that i look like
[Applause]
when i was born
i was born i look like the [ __ ] guy
coming out of the ground
this [ __ ] got caught right here
[Laughter]
every bill's still documented she's just
like is that his shoulders
[Laughter]
oh that [ __ ] hurt bro that [ __ ] was
frozen
but more that came frozen yeah yeah you
better watch out
oh my god why'd you do that mark you're
making fun of my giant ass forehead